حيث قالت قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش
الاوكراني ان قواتها استهدفت قاعده عسكريه
روسيه في رادنسك بمقاطعه خرسون جنوب شرقي
اوكرانيا ونشرت القياده الصور عن قالت
انها توثق عمليه الاستهداف كما نشرت
القياده فيديو الانفجار قالت انه لتدمير
مستودعي ذخيره للقوات الروسيه في منطقه
اوليشكيا المقابله لمدينه خرسون على الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر دينيفر
واعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه مقتله
واصابه عدد من المدنيين اثر استهداف
القوات الروسيه بصواريخ مجنحه وقصف جوي
ومدفعي مناطقه في اوكرانيا واكلت الهيئه
ان قوتها صدت هجمات روسيه في اتجاهات في
مقاطعه
بمقاطعه
كما وصلت هجماتها في مقاطعه ضمن محوري
ميليوتوب وبرديانز
في هذه الاثناء قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان كياف حاولت تنفيذ هجوم بمسيره على
اهداف داخل اراضي الاتحاد الروسي تم
اسقاطها فوق اراضي منطقه بلغراد من جانبه
قال الجيش الاوكراني ان موسم التفجيرات في
القرن سيستمر حتى تحريرها على حد وصفه
ياتي ذلك بعد ان اعلنت سلطات شبه الجزيره
المواليه لروسيا اسقط ثلاثه صواريخ في
منطقه مضيق كرش بينما شددت الخارجيه
الروسيه على ان الهجمات الاوكرانيه في جسر
القرن لن تمر دونا
نرحب بمراسلينا من اوديسا مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي ومن دنيتك مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين دغير ابدا معك نور واخر التطورات
الميدانيه واعلان السلطات الروسيه عن
احباط هجوم اوكراني
نعم بكل تاكيد تلك المنطقه الحدوديه اصبحت
يمكن القول ممرا سهلا للمسيرات الاوكرانيه
التي يبدو انها قد تتجه الى الحدود او
ربما قد يكون مسيرها اعمق باتجاه الداخل
الروسي لكن بكل تاكيد لحد الساعه تتحدث
السلطات العسكريه الروسيه والسلطات
الاقليميه في البولغرد على انها استطاعت
ان توقف كل هذه الهجمات اذا ما حاولنا ان
نعد عدد المسيرات التي تم اسقاطها في
بلغورد من الوقت المتاخر من مساء امس الى
صباح هذا اليوم هناك ما يقارب من خمس
مسيرات تم اسقاطها بالاضافه الى قذائف ما
يقارب من اكثر من عشره قذائف نزلت على
المنطقه يبدو ان هذه المنطقه اصبحت محطه
انظار القوات الاوكرانيه وكنا قد اشرنا
الى ذلك من قبل حيث تعتبر
مناطقيف وسمي احدى الممرات المهمه التي
تحاول ان تتعامل معها القوات الكره
الاوكرانيه باتجاه الجانب الروسي لكن ما
يمكن للحديث عنه هو المستجدات العسكريه
خاصه باتجاه الجنو وبالتحديد باتجاه يبدو
ان العمليات العسكريه بدات تتغير الجانب
الاساسي بالنسبه للجانب الروسي يتحدث على
ان هناك تحرك للقوات الاخرى القوات
الروسيه باتجاه وكذلك باتجاه هارفست لمنع
اي توغل للقوات الاوكرانيه الحديث الروسي
على انه تمكن من تدمير جسر عائم حاولت
القوات الاوكرانيه انزاله من اجل تجاوز
احدى المناطق هنا باتجاه القوات الروسيه
القوات الروسيه تتحدث عن تحطيم هذا الجسر
وكذلك دفع القوات الاوكرانيه للتراجع الى
الورع لكن في هذا السياق الهجومي الذي
تقوم به القوات الروسيه بهذا الاتجاه هناك
شق اخر باتجاه زبولوجيا لكن يقع على
الجانب من دونيتسك ونتحدث عن منطقه
اوريجينا هذه المنطقه بحسب المعلومات
العسكريه الوارده من هناك يبدو ان هناك
هجوما قويا للقوات الاوكرانيه لدفع القوات
الروسيه للخروج
هذه المنطقه يبدو ان القوات تدفع بمزيد من
القوات هناك مقاومه من قبل من قبل القوات
الروسيه لكن يبدو انه لحد الساعه السيطره
الميدانيه على مستوى دفع بالقوات والعتاد
هو لصالح الجانب الاوكراني والسيطره
الدفاعيه للجانب الروسي هل يمكن ان تسقط
هذه المدينه يبدو ان المعطيات العسكريه
ستتبين خلال المراحل المقبله نعم وعامر
الاوكرانيون يتحدثون عن استهداف قاعده
عسكريه روسيه
نشروا صورا قالوا انها توثق هذا الاستهداف
نعم عثمان هذا ما حدث في خرسون وهي عمليات
مستمره تعلم ان نهر دنيبر يفصل بين
الفريقين وبالتالي العمليات هناك اما
عمليات قصف واستهداف لمراكز لاماكن تمركز
للقوات الروسيه او لقواعد او عمليات ان
يقول خاصه يدخل من خلالها عدد من الجنود
عدد محدود يقومون بتنفيذ العمليه وينسحب
بواسطه زوارق صغيره عبر النهر اما هنا في
البحر الاسود خلفي تماما قبل قليل تحدثت
المتحدثه باسم عمليات الجنوب نتاليا
ومنيوك وقالت ان عدد السفن الروسيه في
البحر الان في البحر الاسود وصل الى خمسه
خمسه عشر سفينه خمسه عشره سفينه موجوده
الان في البحر الاسود لكن ليس من بينها
حامله صواريخ وقالت بانها متفرقه بشكل
متفرق وهذا وفقا لها تقول يدل على انهم في
حاله من الخوف والترقب من ان تتم محاوله
استهداف هذه السفن الامر الاخر قالت ايضا
بانهم وضعوا ممر او ممر عبور السفن
المدنيه امام عبور السفن العسكريه كنوع من
الحمايه كما تقول لي هذه السفن لكن ربما
ابرز التصريحات اليوم المتفاعله هنا حقيقه
في اوكرانيا وما قاله المستشار رئيس
الاوكراني ميخائيل الذي قال بان اوكرانيا
الان تقوم بتفعيل الممرات المائيه عبر
البحر الاسود التي كانت مفعله في اتفاقيه
الحبوب وبانها بدات بالفعل وبان روسيا
اصبحت تدرك بان البحر الاسود هو ليس بحيره
خاصه بها وان اوكرانيا ما زالت تقول بان
اتفاقيه الحبوب هي ساريه المفعول مع تركيا
ومع الامم المتحده وبالتالي هي ستقوم
بتنفيذها طبعا واضح ان اوكرانيا هنا تريد
ان تقوم بتنفيذ هذه الاتفاقيه بعيدا عن
موسكو ولكن في كثير من الاخطار نحن تحدثنا
قبل قليل مع المتحدث باسم البحريه
الاوكرانيه وسالناه عن تفاصيل هذه هذا
الكلام او هذه التصريحات قال ان ما جرى هو
ياتي في اطار ما اعلنته القوات البحريه
يوم الخميس الماضي عن تحديد ممرات بحريه
عبر البحر الاسود للسفن العالقه منذ بدايه
الحرب الموجوده في موانع اوديسا وقال
باننا بدانا بالفعل باخذ اسماء الشركات
التي تريد العبور واستخدامها وقال بان
الجيش الاوكراني هو الذي يشرف بشكل كامل
على عمليه العبور وسيبذل كل ما بوس لحمايه
وتامين هذه السفن مع تنبيههم بان الوضع
خطير هناك الغام وهناك مخاطر جراء الاسطول
الروسي الموجود في البحر الاسود شكرا
جزيلا عامر لافي من نوديسه ومن دنيت نور
الدين الدغير